Donald Trump has commuted the sentence of
his campaign associate, Roger Stone.
Roger Stone, therefore, will not be going
to prison where he was scheduled to report
soon.
Now, there's the general discussion here and
then there's the specific discussion.
And I think it makes sense to go in that order
in general when presidents pardon people or
commute their sentences.
It's very common that red flags come up about
connections between the presidents and the
people they are pardoning or whose sentences
they're commuting.
Were they friends or whatever the case may
be in this case? Trump is commuting the sentence
not just of a friend.
To the extent that Donald Trump has friendships,
but of a friend who worked to get Donald Trump
elected.
But it isn't just that.
It's a friend whose crime was directly related
to helping to get Donald Trump elected.
But it's even more the reason that Roger Stone
lied in relation to his work.
Getting Donald Trump elected was to protect
Trump by hiding wrongdoing that Donald Trump
may have been involved in and incomes Donald
Trump and Commute's Roger Stone's sentence.
This is exactly as Republican Senator Mitt
Romney, of all people, said, it is historic
corruption.
Roger Stone was a GO-BETWEEN for the Trump
campaign and WikiLeaks.
Roger Stone was materially involved in the
Trump campaign.
Roger Stone was convicted by a jury for lying
to Congress to protect Donald Trump.
So this is corruption.
This is an abuse of power.
This is a quid pro quo.
Remember that phrase that Trump threw around
to stay strong when it was Paul Manafort and
Michael Cohen?
Trump's former campaign chairman and former
personal lawyer who were under investigation
and under indictment, Donald Trump tweeted
about Manafort is staying strong.
What that means is he's protecting Donald
Trump.
Well, Roger Stone stayed strong in that vein.
He didn't roll over.
He didn't talk about what Trump knew and what
Trump did.
And that is a quid pro quo.
This is arguably a form of bribery.
This is arguably an impeachable offense.
Now, Trump and others will argue, and it's
important to be prepared for this.
They will say the president's power to pardon
and commute sentences is absolute.
Yeah, it's absolute in that a president can
pardon whoever they want to pardon or commute
the sentence sentence of whoever they want
to commute a sentence for.
But that doesn't mean that it can't also be
an act of corruption or a quid pro quo or
a form of bribery.
And only two Republicans so far have actually
called this out for what it is.
One is Mitt Romney, as I mentioned, Mitt Romney
tweeted, quote, unprecedented historic corruption.
An American president commutes the sentence
of a person convicted by a jury of lying to
shield that very president.
Now, you know, good for Mitt Romney.
But remember, Romney voted to convict Trump
on one impeachment count, but he voted to
acquit Donald Trump on obstruction.
And now Mitt Romney is indignant that Donald
Trump is again obstructing.
Give me a break.
So I get it.
Mitt Romney is saying things most Republicans
aren't willing to say.
But at the same time, you acquitted the guy
on obstruction.
You remember that, right?
Then you have Republican Senator Pat Toomey
who said that the prosecution of Roger Stone
was a righteous and appropriate prosecution,
quoting William Barr had to say, and that
if there was a problem with this prosecution,
it really should be resolved via an appeal,
not between not by Donald Trump jumping in
and commuting the sentence of Roger Stone
if Soane was treated unfairly in a real sense.
But we are well within the scope of time during
which an appeal can be made and it could actually
be fought through the courts.
So the action by Trump here is not surprising.
The realization that we've come to is that
until Republicans are forced to do what's
right or stopped from doing what's wrong,
they're going to keep doing it.
And we're you know, I think maybe there's
not that much I have to say about Stone specifically.
I think it's basically, albeit been said.
But what sometimes happens in these situations
is that some on the left will say.
Saying, should we stoop to their level, like,
are they so bad that we should resort to cheating
or violence or corruption in order to get
them out?
Does the ends do the ends justify the means?
And I don't believe so.
I don't think that you can pick and choose
when to play by the rules.
And obviously, it's horrible right now when
we see the degree to which they don't play
by the rules.
I understand saying it.
We would be justified in not playing by the
rules here because we have to get them out.
I think that that would be the wrong instinct.
I believe the path forward should be.
You've got to remove Trump in November, turned
the Senate blue, if not this November, in
November of twenty twenty two.
Maybe this terror of a presidency will affect
enough voters that it will sort of predispose
open up the country to accept real change.
If the Democratic Party gets the country back
under control, I'm no fan of the Democratic
Party as an institution.
But, you know, there are people who are going
to seek to blame Democrats here.
In fact, I've seen some so-called populists
over the last week finding as much to criticize
of Democrats in the context of the Trump fiasco
as they find to criticize about Donald Trump
himself.
I think they're just wrong.
The truth is, Democrats, for all of their
faults and there are many and I talk about
them all the time.
Democrats tried to investigate Trump.
They saw facts which pointed to impeachment
being the right remedy.
And they did it.
It didn't matter.
The Republican Party was never going to go
for it.
We never believed for a second that Trump
was going to be convicted on impeachment.
But the Democrats saw the evidence and said
impeachment is the correct thing.
Democrats were obstructed by the Trump administration
and by Republicans at every turn.
So there are plenty of critiques of the Democratic
Party, and I make them all the time.
But right now, deflecting blame onto the Democratic
Party is the wrong move.
Right now, it's the Republican Party under
Trump ism that either participated in the
attacks on the rule of law or as they stood
aside, as Trump did it himself.
And they need to be held accountable as well.
That's very important.
They are also to blame and you primarily should
be blaming the bad actors.
So I'm not going to play coy with that.
The way there are some people doing New York
maybe should look at prosecuting Roger Stone.
The president can't pardon or commute state
sentences and convictions.
So on the stone matter, that would be something
to look at.
But big picture, we really can't miss the
forest for the trees right now